the higher this drone flies the more
desert it can see
iraq's famous and historic marshes once
covered these lands but not anymore
this is what is left of the ponds citrus
trees and many other types of fruits
that were grown on what was a 400 acre
farm
it was gradually dying due to the
shortage of water first the citrus trees
and then the palm trees have died so
many people have left the area i'm
thinking of leaving but the question is
where should i go you can sell your land
but what comes after that no one knows
the future only god does
what used to be the middle east's
largest food producing region can't feed
itself anymore
over thousands of years the country's
two main rivers the euphrates and the
tigris transformed the desert around
them into green meadows but now 70
percent of the water that once flowed
through them is gone the level of water
and the water supply in the country is
too low
and we started to see this impact on the
very local communities specifically
farmers specifically
people who are living in rural areas
those who are counting on their
livestock to survive those who are
farming on daily basis those who use
water
in every aspect of their daily life
every day this extends from the very
north to the mesopotamian marshes in the
south
drought has reduced these famous marshes
in some areas to puddles and that's
damaging the lives of the people the
wildlife and ecosystems that depend on
them
low water levels are threatening one of
the areas famous animals water buffaloes
these mammals need water to reduce their
body temperature and produce better milk
now herders are forced to buy drinking
water to keep them alive
the environmental crisis are pushing
them to sell their cattle at low prices
and leave to try and find better
opportunities
if water levels continue to decrease
water salinity goes high the taste
becomes bitter and cattles here cannot
drink this water it kills them father is
expensive due to the lack of water and
food the animals fall and die lots of
people have lost many animals
everyone around the marshes knows omar
shikhli he has been researching this
area for almost two decades but has
never seen it this dry
i like always negotiation between turkey
and iran to
agree about what is the shared water
budget that iraq needs at least to
rehabilitate some
deteriorated places or like
area with devastation situation like the
iraqi marshes the continuous decrease of
water budget to the iraqi marshes it
will change the iraqi marshes to a
barren area and the area of a woodland
of the garden of eden will change to a
desert in may al jazeera shot this
footage of the marshes there was much
more water today it's decreasing
endangering these creatures and forcing
their owners to leave their historic
homeland ali hashem al-jazeera chibais
marshes iraq